nos preocupó mucho que los gobiernos no
sepan qué es lo que la gente está
consumiendo y que el mercado ilegal sea
quienes estén dominando la vida de las
personas causa mucha preocupación que a
estas alturas cinco días después de la
muerte de estas personas no sepamos qué
fue lo que estas personas consumieron
las mato esto de alguna manera de vela y
demuestra que la incapacidad que tiene
la institucionalidad de tener por lo
menos patrones de investigación para
saber esta situación y desde eche la
cabeza han afirmado que la lucha contra
las drogas fracasó hace años porque
dicen esto
porque lo que estamos demostrando lo que
es vemos a través de los años es que hay
más consumidores es que hay más
sustancias es que hay más
disponibilidades de sustancias y la
prohibición la guerra contra las drogas
nos prometió era que iba a acabar con
esto hoy en día tenemos que transitar a
otros modelos de atención al consumo
partiendo de la base de que las drogas
no pueden ser eliminadas y que hay
personas que quieren consumir estas
sustancias que son potencialmente
riesgosas para la salud en ese sentido
entonces los servicios de análisis de
sustancias los programas de reducción de
riesgos y daños así como se viene
haciendo con el alcohol con el
cigarrillo que viene con una regulación
importante es hora de transitar ya hacia
la regulación de las sustancias ilegales
para que esto no siga sucediendo señor
criterio éste precisamente menciona los
programas de reducción de riesgos y
daños en qué consisten y cómo pueden
implementarse en américa latina'
para darle un ejemplo concreto en este
caso hay un modelo que se llama
servicios de análisis de sustancias
nosotros tenemos en colombia uno desde
hace diez años en el que le analizamos
las sustancias a las personas que van a
consumir básicamente les decimos sí si
no es la sustancia que aparte de
consumir hemos analizado más de 11.000
sustancias en 10 años y más de 3.500
personas se han salvado de tener una
intoxicación una sobredosis o la muerte
derivada del resultado negativo esa
sustancia los servicios de análisis se
volvieron determinantes en este momento
para contener la epidemia del opioides
en eeuu antes eran unos servicios muy
ubicados en consumidores recreativos en
espacios de fiesta en ocio pero hacer ha
sido determinante para salvarle la vida
a las personas en eeuu pues se puede
identificar
cuando la heroína o la cocaína u otras
sustancias están enfrentan hilo y esto
permite que ellos tomen una decisión y
no la consuman